it seems like too uh there's a
opportunity for someone that's in your
position where you have this kind of
like insecurity and kind of a little bit
of a paranoia against the world
to go down the path of like drug and
alcohol abuse and we all know where that
path ends up if we stay on it
so how did that enter your life i mean
what about there had to be drugs and
alcohol down there what was
what was that like what was that
influence
how how did you manage that part of the
world
yeah you know that's interesting you
know i have family members in my own
close family that have suffered with
addiction and stuff like that
and i really love and i also love
thinking about this kind of stuff like
this kind of stuff for me talking about
feelings and stuff some people say well
you know feelings is the past and
actions is what matters and that's true
i believe that like
i can think all day and it's probably
not going to help me act any different
and i know in my own life if i do act a
certain way my thoughts will follow me
my thoughts really are your troops
really you know uh
um they say in a lot of
recovery rooms that
you can't think your way in the right
action but you can act your way into
right thinking it's a common term and
it's easy for
uh people that struggle with
um addiction or addictive personalities
to understand that it's real simple
um
so
sorry what was the question i felt a
little bit nervous just just as far as
what you know how old were you when
alcohol got introduced how old oh yeah
oh dude i remember i found some liquor
on some
uh
alize liquor some
peach mango starburst baby breath
watermelon something dude on the top
shelf dude it was nine different colors
bro and i found some nudie mags up there
too same time titty literature
so next thing you know dude i'm
ejaculating and just just i remember
falling off the shelf i thought i'm like
i never made it off top shelter there
about four hours here i've never been on
a top shelf you know i don't come from a
real balancing family
so i'm up there dude i'm drinking i'm
[ __ ] masturbating you know and i
remember just blacking out and falling
off that shelf
and i probably fell ma'am
i bet six and a half feet almost eight
feet so not far how old are you at this
time oh i was probably about 13 you know
and so then
but i had other family members who were
struggling with drugs and alcohol so i
had this
really i didn't see that
uh
i didn't see that as like a
a way for me to get in a thing like i
didn't see that as an escape really from
me
so i never used that as an escape um
but as i got a little bit older in my
life i i started realizing that i was
uncomfortable uh
and i was
some of the survival techniques i'd used
as a child weren't helping me anymore
um
[Music]
you mean even the comedy piece even
making people laugh did that start to
wear out
well or what survival was the only
connection that i knew so i had a tough
time making real connections
with people especially women if i wanted
to be in a relationship or
or even i think sometimes friends or
knowing that a connection was safe like
sometimes i'll overdo a connection
somebody will say
yeah everything's fine man we'll be
there and i'll still be hyper worried
about it you know when it's fine it's
somebody else that's totally normal but
um
because somebody some connections
with people are always feel real new and
scary to me i think i was just scared to
make them um
so anyway i started realizing i was
having trouble making real connections
with people
people would say man i feel like i don't
know you but i feel like i would be
sharing a lot of stuff
and so then i i got in
to i started going to some recovery
meetings 12 step
and i couldn't relate to the drugs and
alcohol but i could relate when people
talk about how they felt
you know just
just the feelings and so
i started learning about oh other people
feel some of these ways and it's okay to
have feelings or to struggle with them
and whatever and so that's when i really
started to like being a part of recovery
and there's all types of it you know i
mean there's stuff stuff for everything
there's recovery for people that wear
shirts that don't fit or that fit too
tightly yeah
and i'll struggle with that yeah that's
all right it's really it drags me down
hanging around with echo because i think
[Music]
the sad part is there is a small boy out
there somewhere right now you don't have
a [ __ ]